[Music]
okay I'm outside cinema secrets this is
one of the best places in all of Los
Angeles to get your Halloween costume
and we wonder why our country's running
low on energy
I'm headed in this is interesting the
deal with a lot of Halloween masks is
they're avoiding copyright infringement
this is not a guy fieri costume
this is celebrity chef with this is not
a Donald Trump costume
it's a your fire with this is clearly
Steven Tyler
these are apparently gangster braids I
guess they're gangster braids if it's
1996 and you're being electrocuted this
is tragic
this costume right here actually got an
innocent man killed by SEAL Team six the
whole section up here of historical
costumes for kids that want to get beat
up real fast here's a blast from the
past this was my Halloween costume when
I was 11 I was Teddy Roosevelt I was
wedging 35 times that
presidential election just days away we
got all kinds of political mass got
Barack Obama I think this is an Asian
Schwarzenegger and then this is weird
too
Mitt Romney masks one is pale and one is
burned I don't know why there's two
Romney's maybe because there are in fact
two Mitt Romney's that was a political
comment but he's changed his position so
honey it's time to meet somebody who
works here at the store this is Robin is
that your name Robin hey Robin how are
you
there's a common phenomenon which is the
sexy girl costume
mm-hmm I like to see them on people and
occasionally wear them myself do you
have a section here of sexy girl
costumes we do they're taking me to a
separate section how's it going what are
you doing at the sexy girl section who's
this woman right here just you're the
mom let me get this straight you bring
your mom to the sexy girl
constant section what's going on oh you
brought him even stranger this the maid
the sexy maid is a big one
she's just here to clean up be means
honey but watch out for her sting
quickly going extinct for reasons we
don't understand okay you just found my
favorite I love a cat suit I just think
it's so hot in favor just rub this
against my chest my chest
don't make me say good kitty hey I may
have a new favorite bacon dress my
favorite things
bacon and women's clothing they have a
great series here the douchebag series
this is night douchebag that pirate
douchebag for just douchebag hey Robin I
couldn't help but notice these fake
beards and mustaches are outrageously
expensive check this out this little
mustache alone is 15999 I believe the
mark-up on this is one hundred and fifty
nine dollars
eight cents why are these so expensive
some of them are made out of human hair
and some of them are like what am i
there's some of these up here that are
human hair so this isn't a costume story
you're running this is a serial killers
dungeon now here's a very interesting
phenomenon which is our desire at
Halloween to turn little kids babies
into food this is a little cupcake girl
baby ice cream cone here's baby banana
baby hot dog I don't understand this
need to make children dress up as
something edible they're delicious as is
these all appear to be different kinds
of wounds yes and they're very realistic
this is a guy who's got a horrible burn
this is me after about I think 15
minutes at any Beach in Rhode Island the
scars Jay Leno I think his face is at
his expression is mild annoyance and I
like this one this is
turn-of-the-century Andy Richter
and why is this guy here this is a guy
who just accidentally became a wizard
don't know why he didn't terrible wounds
session okay quick question what the
hell is going on with this you just
noticed this you didn't know that you
were selling I caught on a Brian masse I
have one question for you explain the
title watch him desperately try to win
your approval this is very accurate I
used to be on network I've never been
more attracted to anyone this is my king
by the way this is what I'm into is I
get ladies to put this on and then I'm
with me all night long
okay that does it for me good night and
happy Halloween
[Applause]